Now that we have a better
understanding for
how things can be grouped together
to communicate relationships,
let's talk about the specifics of
laying things out on the screen.
Material design uses an 8dp
grid to align components.
Text aligns to a 4dp baseline grid.
Let's take a closer look at the grid so
you can see it a bit clearer.
Notice that for finer grid control,
the baselines of text sit on a 4dp grid.
That's kind of a subset
of this 8dp grid.
So things like image and
icon sizes, spacing,
margins, and
paddings are all multiples of 8dp.
So things like 16, 72, 40, and
16, those are multiples of 8.
And for text, line heights
are multiples of 4, so 20dp.
These 8dp and 4dp grids allow us to
easily apply the laws of grouping and
keep our UIs organized, balanced, and
in harmony with the rest
of the operating system.
There are material designed templates
and stencils that use this grid,
available for Adobe Illustrator,
Photoshop, and Sketch.
Check the instructor's notes for
links to them.
Even though there's a grid, we need a
couple other pieces to lay out our UIs.
Keylines are used to vertically or
horizontally align objects
in a user interface.
Aesthetically, they enforce
a sense of order in a UI.
They also make it much quicker to scan
the screen and take in the information.
The material design specs suggest some
common keylines to use in mobile design.
Using 16dp margins from the left and
right for auxiliary content like icons,
and avatars, and so on, and
72dp from the left edge for
the primary content, the things like
the page title and the page contents.
Now, if you don't have
auxiliary content,
then your primary content should
probably also align to the 16dp keyline.
And the exact value of these keyline is
less important than the concept aligning
content to bring order to your UI, and
making it quicker to visually parse.
Before we move further,
let me pass it over to James to have you
apply these concepts in Android Studio.